berry FC is more than just a football
club - Kellie Hindle he first came here
aged eight seven decades later it feels
like home
what does berry Football Club mean to
you a lot my life Sunday situation can
you imagine your life without just
football there haven't been any matches
at gig line this season after 134 years
berry may be expelled from the Football
League on Friday because they can't
prove their financial stability fans
believe owner Steve Dale is killing off
the club they say he's had several
offers to sell but is refusing to do so
until he gets more money the players
like former Manchester City prospect
Harry Bunn are still owed several months
of wages financially it's been very
tough you know I know lots of what house
is up for sale you know just you don't
know next week we might be unemployed
and looking for work you know I'm after
me to answer their end of the country to
get work as well it got to the point now
where two days away from going under so
if if there is an offer on the table
then hopefully you know it can get
started the daughter of Barry legend
less heart chained herself to the front
of the stadium in protest she's pleading
for help from the Premier League not
being too melodramatic it will be the
death of very simple as that it would be
so sad we will be a far less rich town
because of Barry because of very going
under but I don't want I want to say
come on clubs northwest clubs you have
the money help us save us you can do it
we would be forever in your debt it's
not only Barry just down the road Bolton
too are struggling to survive
they just say a cobbler struggle in us
some
got some tangible assets let's get in
make a bit of money and then no interest
is slide this guy he's no interest in
football he just wants he's quite happy
to see the club pulled as long as he's
got some money in its pocket a town
waits to see if it's Football Club can
be rescued at the eleventh hour the
future generations too